[Music]
Disney stars can quickly become
household names but not all the names we
know are the actor's real names stay
tuned to find out the original name of
the biggest Disney star can't get enough
of Disney be sure to subscribe to the
things and now here are 10 Disney stars
who changed their name for fame dove
Cameron did you know that the amazing
star of Disney's descendants was born
with another name that's right
dub Cameron's real name is Chloe Celeste
host Ehrman all her family and friends
still call her Chloe we think Chloe
Celeste host Ehrman is such a pretty
name so why did she change it we aren't
sure why she changed her last name to
Cameron but it's definitely easier to
say than host Herman however we do love
the reason she changed her first name
it's so sweet and very sad her dad
always called her dove as a nickname he
called her sister flower but Duff sounds
like a real name he gave her lots of
Dove based nicknames like dovey and of
love sadly her father passed away when
she was just 15 years old as a tribute
to her late father she legally changed
her name to dove it's even on her
passport what an amazing way to honor a
parent who has passed away this just
makes us love her even more we think her
sweetly chosen name sounds perfect for
the popular star we can't imagine seeing
any other name on the credits of our
favorite Disney movies Miley Cyrus
everyone knows pop star Miley Cyrus got
her start on the Disney Channel as
Hannah Montana she played a pop star
with a regular alter ego and then became
a real one with her legal name it wasn't
just her character that had an alter ego
Miley Cyrus was born Destiny Hope Cyrus
because her parents hoped she would have
a destiny of greatness but her dad
country singer Billy Ray Cyrus gave her
the nickname smiling she's got a great
smile so we can totally see why
eventually the nickname morphed into
Miley smiling and then just Miley she
used Miley Cyrus as her acting pseudonym
it definitely rolls off the tongue
smoothly and of course the Hannah
Montana alter-ego used the name Miley -
Miley legally changed her name when she
was 15 in 2008 she adopted the middle
name Rae after her dad now
our full legal name is Miley Ray Cyrus
we think it fits her perfectly we wonder
if any of her other family still calls
her destiny and what does lucky liam
hemsworth call her we're glad Miley got
her start as a Disney Channel star and
we are so glad she did achieve greatness
just like her parents wanted Ricky
Ullman we are travelling back in time
for this next Disney star Ricky Ullman
was the star of the Disney Channel
Original Series Phil of the future
it aired from 2003 until 2006 Phil is a
teenage son of a time-traveling family
from 2121 who got stuck in 2004 it's
hilarious watching them try to fit in
Phil of the future it was really popular
so lots of people knew the name of Ricky
Ullman but Ricky's real name is Raviv
it's an Israeli name he was born in
Israel and immigrated to the United
States when he was a baby he originally
changed his name because he was having a
hard time getting what he called generic
roles
unfortunately actors with non American
names often have a hard time getting
cast but he finally decided to go back
to his birth name to honor his heritage
and really be himself good for you Ravi
we're glad you get to be your true self
what has he been up to since Phil of the
future ended he is active in a couple of
short films and movies and he was also
on the show
Rita rocks but he'll always be a
time-traveling teen heartthrob to us
Sophia Carson that's right some Cameron
isn't the only dissonant star to have
changed her name this very talented
Sophia Carson is a true Disney star she
got her start by guest starring on an
episode of Austin & Ally then she went
on to be cast as our beloved Evie
in the descendants franchised she was
also the star of the movie adventures in
babysitting Sophia is an example of an
actor that changed their name to be
easier to remember Sophia to carrot Shar
gets her birth name from both of her
parents names
her father is Jose asked to carrot and
her mother is a Colombian American named
Laura Shar Carson it's a beautiful name
but sadly stars get more success by
having simpler more American names
Sophia chose the last name Carson from
another family member her American
maternal grandmother
Rainn Carson Sofia chose this name when
she entered acting because it was easier
to pronounce we think both names are
gorgeous
Sofia is almost finished with dissonance
three and we will miss her character
Evie so much but she's already got
another project in the works in 2019
Sofia Carson will be on the new
television show hurry little liars the
perfectionists Jake T Austin we're
throwing it back to 2007 Wizards of
Waverly Place with one of the most
popular Disney Channel shows of all time
it followed the lives of three magical
kids but only one could continue having
magical powers the show dealt with
normal teen issues spiced with untamed
magic and was hilarious sound familiar
it's where we got to know Selena Gomez
Jake TOC and played max the youngest
wizard brother but that's not his real
name Jake was born Jake Austin's is a
man ski much like Sofia Carson he
decided his name with way too hard to
pronounce to have an acting career
he dropped his Polish heritage last name
and used his middle name instead the
middle initial comes from his mother's
maiden name Turan though his mother is
of Latin American descent which helped
to take get another big role if you ever
thought his voice sounded familiar it's
because he voiced Diego on Go Diego Go
from 2005 to 2009 that's right
mischievous max from Waverly Place was
also an animal rescuing preschool
cartoon character Wizards of Waverly
Place ended in 2012 after that he
starred on a TV show called the Fosters
we know his awesome acting name probably
helps launch this talented guy into
success
JC should say we bet you did not expect
to see this guy on this list isn't JC
shows a one of the members of a 90's boy
band he is but before he became a member
of NSYNC he was a star on the all-new
Mickey Mouse Club lots of famous people
got their start on this classic 90s show
including Christina Aguilera Britney
Spears and Ryan Gosling JC shows a
wasn't even the only member of NSYNC to
be a Mickey Mouse Club member the lead
singer and now successful solo pop star
Justin Timberlake
also starred as a Mouseketeer so
is JC on this list JC was born
Joshua Scott Chasse he got the nickname
JC on the set of Mickey Mouse Club there
was another member named Josh so they
call him by his initials so that means
his name technically is Joshua she's a
she's a when Mickey Mouse Club was
cancelled he and Justin Timberlake
wanted to form a musical group and they
were later joined by the other three
members of NSYNC together they became a
worldwide phenomenon JC is a pretty big
star with the most famous Disney star of
all time also had a name change keep
watching to find out who's Raven Symone
no Disney star video would be complete
without Raven Raven starred on the
extremely popular That's So Raven as a
teenage psychic who gets into outrageous
situations and the best part is she's
back on the Disney Channel ravens home
follows psychic Raven as a single mom
who was living with her twins her best
friend Chelsea and Chelsea's son yes the
original Chelsea is back - everyone
knows her by the name Raven Symone or
even just as raven but her full name is
Raven Symone christina Pearman she's so
talented she doesn't need all those
names in addition to her own show on
Disney she starred in the Disney Channel
Original Movies Cheetah Girls and
Cheetah Girls
- she voiced Monique on Kim Possible and
played nebula on the Zenon movies and
that's not even all of her Disney
credits but how did the world first come
to know and love Raven she starred as
the sassy hilarious young daughter
Olivia Huxtable on The Cosby Show in the
early 1990s Raven is incredibly talented
and we're still glad she's back to her
Disney roots we love that she's so cool
she doesn't need her last name Chelsea
Kane if you're a die-hard Disney fanatic
like us
you probably remember Chelsea Kane from
the show Jonas she played Stella Malone
on the fictionalized version of the
Jonas Brothers lives Chelsea did things
a little different from other Disney
stars she starred in two Disney Channel
Original Movies before starring on a
show she starred in 2008 minute
and then played Alexis in starstruck two
years later but on the Disney Channel
she is credited with a different last
name Chelsie stop is her birth name and
she got really annoyed with no one being
able to pronounce it she heard a lot of
Chelsea stabbed and Chelsea's stuff it's
kind of hard to become a household name
if no one can pronounce it she
officially changed her acting name in
2011 although she had starred in the
movie brats before her stint as a Disney
star Chelsea Kane became really
successful after Jonas ended she had
starred in several television series
since then her most famous was the show
baby daddy she even had a few episodes
on the hit show One Tree Hill Chelsea
Cain is definitely easier to remember
for this awesome and talented actress we
can't wait to see where her career takes
her next doc Shaw
doc Shaw got his Disney Channel career
started as Marcus little on suite life
on deck but did you know he was starring
on another television show at the same
time he played Malik Payne on Tyler
Perry's House of Payne for an amazing
119 episodes he must have been super
busy doc is super talented and Disney
noticed it so they gave him his own show
in 2010 he starred as King Duke boomer
Parker on pair of kings in this show he
played a twin who discovers he is one of
the heirs to an island dock with a
hilarious teenage king and the f he was
still filming House of Pain during a lot
of this time docs real name is Laramie
Cortes saw his grandparents gave him the
nickname doc as a young boy they noticed
some special talent of his who knows if
he had not been such a successful child
star maybe he would have been a doctor
he definitely can handle the busy
schedules of one Doc has had a few more
credits since pair kings ended and
sometimes he uses the name of Laramie
dark Shaw but he still showed up on the
credits as doc Shaw when he acted as ash
in dawn of the planet of apes Mickey
Mouse there's no doubt about it
Mickey Mouse is the most famous Disney
star of all time he's also the world's
most famous Mouse but did you know that
Mickey Mouse started the trend for name
changes at Disney the first time we ever
see everyone's favorite mouth his name
Steamboat Willie Walt Disney illustrated
this short cartoon in 1928 in it
Steamboat Willie drives a steamboat and
engages in hilarious shenanigans to beat
the villain hi Clegg Pete this cartoon
is actually a parody of a real 1920s
film called steamboat bill jr. starring
the classic movie star Buster Keaton
Walt Disney was smart to make his first
cartoon recognizable and relatable this
is also the cartoon where Minnie Mouse
makes her appearance Mickey Mouse
definitely rolls off the tongue easier
and he's recognized all over the world
you can't have Disney without Mickey
this name change and sensational cartoon
launched Walt Disney's Empire and that
way the things are so obsessed with it
was a huge hit ann's Mickey Mouse
appeared with the name we know and many
more cartoons which Disney name change
shocked you the most don't be shy let us
know in the comments those are tender
new stars who changed their name for
fame if you love Disney just as much as
we do subscribe to the things and don't
forget to hit that notification valve to
be told when we released a new episode
thanks for watching
[Music]